yeah I think scientifically it would be
just almost cataclysmic I think that
people would get very excited about the
topic we'd have lots of missions to go
land on the surface really get
substantial sample even maybe bring some
back to earth that would be a very very
exciting day I don't think that it would
have as big of an effect culturally well
because I I just think people didn't
think much of microbes microbes get no
respect so it's not about our size and
curator so I I think I think that the
moment the moment that really would be a
cataclysm and it's depicted in he in
contact and when he contact them in the
book which is even better right is if we
ever find an indisputable signal from an
intelligent civilizations I think that
would that would be what people really
have to come to grips with the fact that
I'm involved our state and and in fact
if we ever hear from another
civilization chances are excellent that
they are well beyond us if you just work
out the numbers like work through the
Drake Equation that's how it works out
in order for us to even hear signals
from someone else it means it means that
they are well advanced beyond us they've
had to they've had to learn things like
how to manipulate the energy of their
star in order to build their
civilization